lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
probar uno de los resultados más útiles
para geometría de ángulos en la
circunferencia dice lo siguiente dice
que la medida de un ángulo inscrito un
ángulo inscrito simplemente es un ángulo
que tiene un vértice sobre la
circunferencia entonces la medida de un
ángulo digamos de este estilo lo voy a
poner algo así
esta medida que le vamos a llamar si voy
a utilizar la letra griega pge y para
las medidas de ángulos inscritos
entonces el resultado dice que si la
medida de este ángulo es igual a la
mitad de la medida del ángulo central
que abre el mismo arco ahí hay un montón
de palabras sofisticadas pero la idea es
muy simple dice lo siguiente dice nos
fijamos en él en el arco que define este
ángulo inscrito o sea aquí hay dos
puntos esos dos puntos definen este arco
este arco de la circunferencia y ese
arco de la circunferencia define un
ángulo central déjame pintar el ángulo
central en color azul
en este de acá
y este de aquí entonces lo que dice este
resultado es que si este ángulo central
mide theta
entonces la medida del ángulo inscrito
es la mitad de la medida del ángulo
central o sea si es igual a un medio un
medio de teta sin importar cuál en un
inscrito o sea eso está súper
impresionante y después va a ser útil
para muchos otros resultados lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es mostrar
por qué siempre sucede déjame empezar
con un caso sencillo voy a borrar esto
y voy a empezar con el siguiente caso el
caso es cuando uno de los lados uno de
los lados del ángulo inscrito pasa justo
por el centro de la circunferencia algo
más o menos de este estilo sale entonces
este sería uno de los lados del ángulo y
el otro vamos a pintarlo digamos por acá
algo de este estilo déjame marcar que
estoy aquí me de pge y me de pepsi y en
este caso vamos a observar lo siguiente
de aquí del vértice del ángulo al centro
de la circunferencia es un radio pero
también de éste de este punto del centro
de la circunferencia a este de acá
tenemos un radio porque justo este punto
está sobre la circunferencia y la
circunferencia es el lugar de los puntos
aún a una misma distancia de un centro
entonces si éste es r estoy acá también
ese r bueno si este es r y éste es r
este triángulo es un triángulo isósceles
y como este ángulo mide eps y este
ángulo de acá también mide pge y
también mide si a lo mejor estás
acostumbrado a verlo de otra forma o sea
si tenemos un triángulo así verdad donde
esté mide lo mismo que este entonces
este ángulo este ángulo mide lo mismo
que este ángulo de acá pero bueno el
chiste es que pudimos pasar este ángulo
y para acá y ahora vamos a poner aquí el
ángulo theta que nos interesa el ángulo
theta porque justo justo el arco que
abre el ángulo inscrito es este de acá
arriba este de acá arriba y por lo tanto
el ángulo central correspondiente dice
que a cabo el que acabo de marcar como
theta este de acá vale entonces nos
gustaría ver que teta es el doble de sí
o bien que si mide la mitad de teta
bueno si estoy aquí es teta esté acá por
ser suplementario mide 180 grados menos
teta pero ahora vamos a utilizar que la
suma de los ángulos internos de un
triángulo es 180 grados entonces
tendríamos que sí más sí o sea dos veces
sí
más 180 menos teta 180 grados menos teta
es igual a 180 grados otra vez esto es
por la suma de los ángulos internos de
un triángulo cancelamos 180 con 180 y
nos queda que dos veces si dos veces si
menos teta menos teta es igual a cero o
bien ya lo voy a poner en color verde
que dos veces si es igual a detalle eso
es justo lo que queríamos bueno es lo
que queríamos después de dividir entre
dos o sea o más bien antes de dividir
entre dos dividiendo entre dos nos queda
que si es igual a t está dividido entre
dos vale la medida del ángulo inscrito
es la mitad del ángulo central o bien el
ángulo central mide el doble que el
inscrito pero pero hasta ahorita sólo es
para un caso sencillo verdad para el
caso en el cual este lado uno de los
lados podemos pensarlo como como rayo
uno de los rayos
que define el ángulo pasa por el centro
de la circunferencia bueno de todas
formas esto es bastante bueno verdad o
sea por ejemplo si supiéramos que este
teta mide 60 grados
entonces sabríamos que si es de 30
grados es de 30 grados y así ya
podríamos resolver varios problemas pero
nos gustaría también poder mostrar este
resultado para cuando tenemos otro tipo
de ángulos así que déjame déjame borrar
y vamos a hacer otro caso más ahora
vamos a hacer el caso en el cual el
ángulo el ángulo inscrito contiene al
centro de la circunferencia es decir
queda más o menos como algo de este
estilo
vale algo de este estilo y después vemos
el último caso bueno en este caso déjame
déjame marcar todo lo que nos interesa
este ángulo de acá eso sí aquí
tendríamos el arco que ya no lo voy a
pintar pero bueno ahí tendríamos el arco
que define este ángulo inscrito acá
tendríamos el ángulo teta que es el
ángulo central correspondiente teta y
nos gustaría ver otra vez que teta es el
doble de pepsi o que si es la mitad de
teta pero ya sabemos cómo hacerle cuando
uno de los lados del ángulo es el
diámetro entonces vamos a aprovechar eso
y vamos a dibujar un diámetro
que pase por el vértice y por el centro
vale así entonces observa que tanto si
como te estás quedan divididos en dos
ángulos que corresponden al caso que ya
teníamos eso está muy padre verdad
déjame embarcar lo más explícitamente o
sea este ángulo si queda dividido aquí
en un ángulo en un ángulo pge y uno
si uno
voy a poner un poco más bonito y uno y
de este lado un ángulo y dos y dos y del
otro lado o más bien aquí donde están
los ángulos centrales theta queda
dividido en un ángulo theta 1
y un ángulo theta 2 y ahora podemos
aplicar lo que ya mostramos en el caso
anterior como tenemos que este ángulo
este ángulo de acá tiene uno de sus
lados pasando por el centro entonces z 1
teta 1 30 1 es igual a 2 veces si 1
dos veces si uno y de manera similar
teta 230 2
voy a ponerlo más a la izquierda para
que quede más alineado es igual a dos
veces dos veces si dos otra vez esto lo
podemos asegurar porque también este
ángulo que queda ahora de este lado
tiene uno de sus lados que pasa por el
centro vale bueno vamos a sumar estas
dos igualdades si las sumamos tenemos
que teta 1
más tentados es igual a dos veces si uno
dos veces y dos déjame factorizar el 2 2
veces y uno más si 2
vale simplemente factor hice el 2 pero
está padrísimo porque esto de acá está
uno más de tazos este está el ángulo
central con el que habíamos iniciado es
igual a dos veces estoy acá pero esta
suma si uno más si dos es el original es
igual a dos sí y por lo tanto dividiendo
entre dos de ambos lados tenemos que si
es igual a teta teta entre dos entonces
con eso completamos también este caso en
el cual el centro queda en el interior
del ángulo inscrito ya nada más nos
falta un caso cuando el centro queda
fuera de este de este ángulo vamos a
hacerlo
vamos a eliminar lo que pusimos y vamos
a poner ahora un ángulo de los que
faltan que sería algo más o menos hacia
un ángulo de este estilo no tiene al
centro en su interior vale entonces por
aquí tenemos este punto y este punto
este ángulo de acá que nos interesa es
si el ángulo central tiene que abrir
este mismo arco
entonces nos quedaría así
este con este vamos a ponerle que este
mide teta y nos gustaría ver como
siempre que teta es el doble de sí o que
si es la mitad beteta bueno este caso
también tiene un truco similar a la
anterior como sabemos cómo se comportan
estos ángulos cuando cuando trazamos
líneas por diámetros pues justo vamos a
trazar una línea una línea que sea un
diámetro una línea de este estilo que
pase por el centro pues
y entonces al hacer esto se nos forman
dos ángulos dos ángulos en los cuales
uno de los lados pasa por el centro este
ángulo de acá y este ángulo de acá vale
déjame llamarle a este ángulo
a este ángulo de acá si uno si uno y
observa que ese ángulo si uno abre este
arco y abre este arco y por lo tanto el
ángulo central correspondiente es este
de acá que vamos a llamarle theta uno
te dan 1 vale entonces aplicando el
primer caso que vimos en si uno intenta
uno tenemos lo voy a escribir por acá
déjame ponerte está uno con otro color
para para que sea un poco más fácil y
siguiendo lo vamos a ponerlo en color
rojo que está bueno vamos a ponerlo así
nada más teta teta 1 vale entonces
tenemos que teta uno es igual a dos
veces si uno
es igual a dos veces si uno vale eso es
aplicando el primer caso en este ángulo
de acá pero también podemos aplicar el
primer caso en este ángulo de acá en
este y este ángulo con su ángulo central
correspondiente que ahora sería este de
acá y este de acá vale entonces ahí
tendríamos que teta más te está 1
te da más de 130 1 es igual al doble al
doble
de si más si uno entonces vamos a
ponerlo así sin más
si uno más si si uno desarrollando del
lado derecho pero me volver a escribir
lo tenemos teta más de 130 1 es igual a
dos veces sí
dos veces sin más dos veces y uno más
dos veces y uno
si uno y sustituyendo theta uno aquí
abajo tenemos que teta más dos veces y
uno más dos veces sí
es igual a dos veces si dos veces sin
más dos veces si uno dos veces si uno y
aquí podemos restar dos veces si uno de
ambos lados y obtenemos justo lo que
queríamos que teta teta
es igual a dos veces si dos veces si o
bien si es igual a theta entre dos que
está entre dos y listo con esto ya
cubrimos todos los posibles casos que
podíamos tener cuando cuando el centro
pasa por el interior del ángulo cuando
pasa por el exterior y cuando el centro
está sobre uno de los lados del ángulo
vale este resultado está muy interesante
es muy sencillo es muy fácil de decir y
además lo vamos a utilizar para seguir
haciendo muchas más cosas en el círculo
y para construir otro tipo de ángulos y
encontrar otras propiedades vale
nos vemos en siguientes vídeos